[Music]
you mentioned that you know that you you
have all these you know problems and
suspicions about being in a relationship
and that it's difficult for you you're a
road come if you're on the road
constantly touring yeah that's got a
wreak havoc on you doesn't yeah I behave
you know I stay in my room I do what we
do with the computer but like you know
what's weird is I was on the road am I
getting okay I'll tell you I was on the
road and I like I was sitting in in my
hotel room and I just started thinking
about auto-erotic asphyxiation now look
I know I'm not gonna do it I was just
thinking like that you know that's
really a road thing yeah I decided that
no one's doing that at home you know
that's strictly a business trip kind of
thing like I yeah I picture men leaving
the house for a trip saying honey
where's that belt I always bring you
know the belt with the weird notches I
don't know how that happened but then I
started to think like me I think it was
discovered in a hotel room cuz think
about it I travel a lot
yeah alright and usually if you're
traveling alone even if it's for a day
or two at some point during that hotel
stay you will sit in your hotel room and
you will think I want to kill myself
right and usually what happens with me
is a few minutes later you say now just
masturbate you know
okay so okay I don't like where this is
going so I'm figuring how long before
you like hey maybe we can bring these
two things maybe we could take this
masturbation thing to the next level
right I want it to be white bright say
oh it's butter and jelly yeah but I'd
like I haven't tried it I don't I don't
want to try cuz that'd be a disaster I
could just see myself like I don't
really know how to do it with my belt I
think I need a door and then I'd be like
oh I better google it you know I don't
want to be in that room this doesn't
come up a lot on television show this is
the show to bring it up don't use the
right think is the place to resolve
these issues let's try it no one should
see how I see the edge see how far we're
gonna if we're gonna do that we're gonna
do it during sweeps yeah that's gonna be
our sweet
[Laughter]
now you're acting it out do the whole
motion planet thanks you thank you for
not doing the whole motion such maturity
job I've got my line wow this is like
front line we're getting ready buddy
here
good god I do worry about you I just
want you to know that I'm worried about
I'm fine today right now I mean in this
moment you're fine right now because
sure about it's going away what it's
gone away yeah it was just good for a
second but then I started thinking about
it now we're in trouble where we go well
I know I can suspect me are you staying
at a hotel while you're out here yeah I
live 10 minutes from here but I got a
room I'll see you there what's wrong
with this show
none of this is arable love it and I
blame you I know you want me to come out
again and we'll start oh no no no no
it's just a pity you got all dressed up
and everything what yeah you look like
you're gonna put caulk in the bathroom
Wow - it
okay Jason see
[Applause]